Captain.
While a great many people see you as a hero,...
...there are some who'd prefer the word vigilante.
You've operated with unlimited power and no supervision.
That's something the world can no longer tolerate.
I know how much Bucky means to you.
Stay out of this one.
Please.
You'll only make this worse.
You're saying you'll arrest me?
There will be consequences.
Captain, you seem a little defensive.
Well, it's been a long day.
If we can't accept limitations, we're no better than the bad guys.
That's not the way I see it.
Sometimes I want to punch you in your perfect teeth.
I'm sorry, Tony.
You know I wouldn't do this if I had any other choice.
But he's my friend.
So was I.